signs that russian forces are preparing
for a major new offensive stepping up
shelling in the eastern part of the
country as many civilians who live there
are trying to flee flee for their lives
ukraine's armed forces are also bracing
for a new onslaught and at this crucial
moment what we're going to do is share
with you an unprecedented look at the
man in charge of ukraine's war effort
and what it's like for him inside his
headquarters in kiev i'm talking of
course about ukraine's president
volodomir zielinski he allowed 60
minutes to visit his fortified and
blacked out war rooms in the capitol and
he spoke with our scott pelley they
discussed a wide range of issues
including his views on nato's response
to the war so
far mr president in a speech to nato you
said quote
all the people who die
will die because of you
because of your weakness
are you saying that the west
bears some responsibility for these
atrocities
he told us
i remember all of us remember books
about the second world war and about the
devil in
uniform adolf hitler
are those countries who did not
participate in the war responsible
the countries who let german forces
march throughout europe does the world
carry responsibility for the genocide
yes
yes it does
when you have the ability to close the
sky
yes it's scary that a world war could
start it's scary i understand that and i
cannot put pressure on these people
because everyone is afraid of war
but whether the world is responsible for
this
i believe so yes i believe so
stand in front of the mirror every day
and ask yourself were you able to do
something or were you unable to do
something
you will find the answer in the mirror
to this question
and to another
that's what i believe
and as the world reflects on that
question standing before the mirror as
he puts it it's been 50 days or nearly
so since the russian invasion began and
president zielinski also spoke to scott
pelley about the outcome in this war
that he would like to see
what does winning look like to you
but a more
victory
first of all our people would definitely
feel victory they will come back the
return of refugees is blood for the body
of ukraine without them there's nothing
the bombardments would end
we would recover our territory
there would be no russian soldiers in
our country
yes i understand they will not withdraw
from crimea and will be arguing and
negotiating for one territory or another
in the south of our country
i know exactly what has to happen after
which we can say this is victory
but if you don't mind
i'm not going to talk about it just yet
mr president we
wish you all the luck in the world
i need
half of it i think even half will be
enough
yeah it's an interview that has the
heavy feel of history just 12 hours
later you can see that interview in its
entirety now at 60minutes.com and on our
streaming service paramount plus the
entire interview with president
zielinski has also been posted on the 60
minutes youtube page check it out can we
just say that even if if by chance you
missed that interview it really is worth
your time watching i've never seen
anything like it on television the
access that scott had and i've never
seen zielinski i mean he's always a
straight talker but the way that he
talked to scott pelley and it was
interesting scott's translation yes that
he did in his own voice where you got it
was i felt we were watching something
very important in real time they're
sitting there in the dark at this hinge
moment in history and everything that
the the president is saying are echoing
back in time and also forward in the
decades